okay the second game North black first
one was a draw after I am had some time
problems with the totally one end came
okay now i'm now I Catalonia he likes to
I likes to play the g3 there I remember
okay let's go with some quick moves and
not waste too much time
yeah this is maybe not the best setup in
the world but at least I could played in
20 seconds
White has some nice space advantage
I've got some counter play on the a6 f1
dragon although the bishop um is quite
actively placed most likely he will
sacrifice upon now okay I can I could
actually take on c4 it's always
difficult to access but I'd like to have
a porn at least for this position which
of course is some somewhat passive okay
let's take the second one as well came
maybe just a 97 trust a six was hanging
so I had to do something okay and always
coming with some night g try to get
something going on the c4 yeah not much
choice I don't want to weaken the
position okay
yeah this looks very uncomfortable to
say the least 96 simply threatens to win
the Queen at the moment but it's really
an ugly position most likely I have to
give at least exchange here yeah play
like to be eight he might even go Knight
f6 this could this could work already
yeah I don't see I don't see anything
else not d6 of course just wins the
exchange but Knight f6 or take Bishop
takes us 697 Queenie to take on a six
yeah this could be a winning attack
yeah this was just a really crap opening
that I played there yep okay let's check
now do I have something else 197 he also
might simply play Bishop takes f6 and I
could give the Queen maybe but wow yeah
well not much choice I think without
taking this it's it's over anyway
okay anything else then taking I don't
think so well at least I only have eyes
got rookie fall so it should be three
then maybe but I is taking this first ok
ok quindi 8 rookie for simply was the
deadly threat on our threatened to take
the route and threaten well ideas to
exchange the Queen maybe I'm still alive
here maybe it still looks dangerous
seventies Queen h6 maybe take on a six
this should be fun can f two f5s I know
at five
yeah should really also ignore the
spectators because they're cute sing
some moves here but well yeah ya think
yes to exchange really not sure if this
attack is really going through if he
needs to retreat the Queen I think Queen
age 6 is not working because I can
really take and play a five then he goes
for it amazing yeah well I don't take
the rook but I have f5 Bishop f4 f5
takes and then covering the seventh was
Queen d700 guess and I don't see it well
if it's got a mate then he's played a
brilliant game so what can you do Queen
d7 now look that's coming now
it's an old rock and the Bishop b4 also
prevents the rock from getting lift
lifted to g4 maybe we need to retreat
the bishop now yeah and then try to get
in the rook I could go big night be for
now rookie form or will be five takes up
g5 the Rope g7 now well still so far
from easy
Luke group before the rook f7 maybe yeah
I need to speed up it just takes it okay
okay still awfully awfully dangerous at
least the rookies hanging now yeah but I
have this covered really
I don't I don't see anything objectively
it's just winning from like now
maybe I forgave one with the counter
tech now yeah well well yeah tough fight
booked games well thanks for watching
and you welcome to leave any questions
or comments in YouTube and please also
check out the other video I kingscrusher
by